my name's Ben and I'm gonna be talking
today about generative art this is
something that I've been doing for about
a year now and it's come it's kind of
turned into a kind of psych gig for me I
really like it and I'm really excited to
share with you guys kind of what the the
tools that we use look like and in
particular what my tool set looks like I
can't speak for every artist out there
but this is kind of the stuff that I've
I've personally used to create my work
and I've seen used by other people doing
similar things I do need to preface this
by saying that there are a couple of
animations in this presentation that
I've been told are a little bit fast
they're not like blinking lights or
anything but I feel like I need to issue
just a seizure warning if anybody is
particularly sensitive to that so during
the day what I do is I work at this
company called freckle 2 wonderful
company education company writing
Haskell code all day which I would love
to talk about but it's not why I'm here
so that's what I do it during the day
and at night this is kind of what my
computer turns into I I write code that
generates art using random generation
and 2d vector graphics this is just a
screenshot that I took the other day
these are a couple more pieces of my
work that you might have seen kind of
floating around the internet if you're
into this kind of thing and the goal of
this talk is to shed some light on what
what tools I use to create stuff like
this and there are a couple of pieces in
this in this presentation that are not
my own they're Creative Commons stuff
but anything that's not captioned with
the artists name is mine so if you have
any questions that you want to submit
through slide oh I think it's about any
of these pieces if you're curious about
how they were created I'd be happy to
answer those in the Q&A session at the
end just shoot a question my way
okay so how many of you are familiar
with generative art and what that means
okay
cool it's like good at least half of the
audience I'd say so I struggled to
define this for a very long time until
this guy Jason Bailey very recently
published an article about it
he he does a lot of work with like art
history and he published this really
good article about the history of
generative art but his definition as
noted in the article is generative art
is art programmed using a computer that
intentionally introduces randomness as a
part of its creation process and I think
that's very precise people have
different differing definitions about
this but I think this one's really good
so if you kind of remove the computer
component of this you might have
splatter art or something like that art
that kind of has a little bit of
randomness involved with it kind of like
Jackson Pollock's paintings and if you
remove the randomness then you get
digital art so traditional kind of
digital paintings or what have you but
when you combine the two you get
generative art and I've found that my
process is a lot of trying to balance
the ideas of kind of complete control
and complete chaos to produce something
that is like visually appealing but not
boring and not too not too crazy and I
call that the sweet spot the interesting
thing is that computers are really good
at both they're really good at
generating completely random garbage
data and they're really good at doing
things completely perfectly so you
really have to a lot of my work is just
trying to balance those concepts
together to produce something visually
appealing
so as programmers we the first step
towards doing anything is gathering
domain knowledge about that thing so I
feel like I should talk a little bit
about the domain of art and and what it
is so this is kind of what you might
learn in a in a high school college
course on
art you know 101 the elements and
principles of artwork so this is a piece
by PM andre on composition 2 in red blue
and yellow and it displays a bunch of
these elements of art which I'll go
through now so you've got color
obvious form is kind of 3d form or the
implication of 3d form which isn't here
and that's okay
lines shapes space refers to like
negative and positive space so for
example in this piece you've got
positive space in the red blue and
yellow portions and then those white
pieces kind of fall into the background
that's called negative space texture
again there's not a lot of texture here
but that's okay
and value refers to the brightness of
colors in your in your artwork and we'll
talk a little bit more about that later
here as well and then I like to add an
eighth element of generative art because
you can't really have generative art
without randomness as we just said but
randomness is another kind of component
just a primary component of of artwork
and the elements of artwork are just the
things that you use to create art and
then the principles of art are kind of
how you use those elements to produce
something that means something and so
these are things like balance which
refers to symmetry and asymmetry
emphasis which refers to you know
focusing on a certain portion of the
artwork as opposed to something else
things that might fall into the
background movement is kind of how your
eye moves through the artwork proportion
thing things can be bigger than others
rhythm is this idea that you might have
some repetition in your artwork but it
may not be perfect and so you have to
kind of carefully consider how that
factors into your compositions and then
unity and variety refer to kind of the
sameness or difference in your work so I
might have squares and circles in my
artwork and you know the squares might
be clustered together that's unity
but you also have some circles there and
that's variety and I additionally I like
to add an eighth principle of generative
art is what I call the eighth principle
of generative art emergence very very
common in generative art is this idea
that the the piece of art just kind of
blossoms into something that you didn't
expect and that's this idea of emergence
and you can see it pretty clearly in a
lot of generative artwork so on the
right we've got a piece by Kandinsky
composition 8 and you can kind of dig in
and see some of these principles in
action one of my favorite is the
movement of your eye when you look
through this piece is really interesting
there are so many lines kind of pointing
in different directions but your eye
just kind of follows them throughout the
whole piece and you can kind of pick up
on some other things as you as your eye
moves through it
so elements I like to think of as being
provided by a tool so a pen will give
you a line maybe a sponge with with
paint on it will give you like a texture
and so those kind of those things are
are kind of provided to you by a tool
which in our case might be a graphics
library like processing or I personally
use Cairo and the principles of art are
those elements of your compositions that
the human puts there so things like
symmetry you're gonna have to explicitly
state you're gonna have to say I want
cemetry in my piece if you want a sense
of rhythm in your piece you're gonna
have to carefully craft that somehow and
so we use the the elements are kind of
given to us and the principles are what
we what we can what we want to achieve
using those elements cool so onto
generative art what is the generative
arts canvas I would say
is for me at least is the the two
dimensional Cartesian plane so just as a
visual artist that works in 2d might
work on a canvas we work on the
Cartesian plane typically this is
represented by computers as zero zeros
in the top left I don't know why there
might be some historic reason for that
but uh it's a common like gotcha at the
beginning and kind of messing around
this sort of thing something to look out
for so we can represent points on our on
our canvas as 2d card Cartesian
coordinates and we can modify those
things using vectors and linear algebra
I think it's really it's not hard to get
a basic understanding of linear algebra
and it's super helpful in kind of
getting your art to do things that you
might want it to do so for example if
you have two points on the Cartesian
plane you can translate one by the other
and that's a linear algebra vector
operation and linear algebra gives us
the ability to implement like scaling of
shapes translation of shapes rotations
of things and all that good stuff so
it's it's really useful to have that in
our tool belt cool and so the next thing
that I'll talk about we just talked
about kind of single points the next
thing that we might want to do is
connect two points together lines line
segments are really great at doing this
so you might have a class in your in
your program that just stores two
different Cartesian coordinates and you
can draw a line between them and this is
a really really good primitive thing to
have in your program because it you can
combine them in really interesting ways
and sort of the generalization of that
is the path so a path is endpoints all
connected in a single line so you can
see on the animation I'm just generating
a whole bunch of points in the middle
there and then
connecting them all with a path and you
can see it just kind of goes most
graphics libraries really provide you
this nicety out of the box so you can
just say like start path draw some
points and path done and then very
similarly for shapes so you can see in
this we're doing the same kind of thing
except generating points kind of around
a little rectangle and then connecting
those points at the end and filling in
the shape I you can also most graphics
libraries will give you the option of
drawing like a rectangle or a circle and
those are really common things to do as
well but you can also do kind of
freeform shapes like this which is a
really nice tool cool and so now I want
to talk a little bit about the element
of randomness in generative art these
are two of my pieces wired T and yr s
they were generated from the same
program on you there are three kind of
key pieces of this that vary a bunch the
first is the kind of obvious one of the
wires don't follow the same path so they
they kind of follow different paths the
second thing that you might notice is
that the fraying on the wires is totally
different so why are s has this kind of
interesting bend in one of the wires
that I really like
whereas YRT doesn't really have that but
they both have that fraying property and
then the third thing that I like to
point out that's extremely subtle is
that the the stippling on the back in
these little rectangles in the
background while they have the same
value kind of going down they they
follow the same kind of value
progression the actual distributions of
those dots is totally different so if
you look super closely then you'll see
that the dots are not the same so how do
we do this we use pseudo random number
generation typically your whatever
programming language you're using is
going to have some way of generating a
random value I use live
that gives me a little bit more than
that so I can get generate normally
distributed or Gaussian distributed
values using my tools and there are
implementations out there for a lot of
things so I wanted to kind of walk
through what each of these things is
doing I'm filling in for squares with
random dots in each in each square but
they look totally different because the
way that we're generating those points
is totally different
so at the top right is kind of the most
basic one
it's just picking a random x and y
coordinate within the square at with a
completely uniform distribution and
doing that 10,000 times you can see it
just kind of turns into a grayish box to
the left of that we're doing the same
thing except before generating a point
the the box is split into 16 sub boxes
each of those boxes is assigned a weight
and a box to generate a point in is
chosen based on that weighted
distribution before drawing it so what I
like about this is that I didn't like
you can tell that the the top-left boxes
are a little bit they're weighted higher
because they're darker and at the bottom
left they're weighted less the the
weight is less but kind of like an
interesting pattern fell out of this and
it was totally random like the little
Center there just looks like for like a
little window and then it looks like
it's kind of boxed by other things but
but it is 16 completely independent
squares so moving down into the bottom
on the right is a normal distribution
centered around the center of the square
both x and y coordinates are normally
distributed around the middle and then
on the left is kind of a combination of
the two so the x coordinate is is chosen
in a uniform distribution along the top
and then the Y coordinates are are
normally distributed
actually half normally distributed
because they fold over the top like that
along the top so the other really nice
kind of pseudo-random thing that we can
talk about is purling or simplex noise
this is a really really useful tool for
introducing movement into your
generative art the idea behind noise is
that you have or at least these two
noise algorithms I don't know if this is
true in general the idea behind simplex
or Perlin noise is that you can give it
a vector of n of dimension N and it'll
spit out a number between 0 and 1 the
interesting property is that any inputs
that are close together if you have two
vectors in 2d space that are close
together if you call noise on those
there the noise value will be very close
in value as well so this is really cool
for for instance like making this cool
3d this cool animation so each frame you
can kind of tell well let me back up a
little bit so what's happening here is
I'm sampling a sampling Perlin noise
sampling simplex noise at a whole bunch
of grid points and then I'm taking
whatever value that is and turning it
into a unit vector at that spot that
points in an angle that corresponds to
the number between 0 and 1 so it's just
then zero and one is interpolated
between 0 and 2pi and then we use that
as an angle to kind of generate that
little arrow so at each slice of this
animation at each frame you can see kind
of a slice of 2 dimensional simplex
noise and you can you can see that
things there are around each other kind
of follow the same pattern and your eye
will kind of flow through this in a
smooth way and then additionally this is
actually three dimensional simplex noise
that I'm using here because I want the
transitions between frames to be nice as
well so you're kind of seeing this like
three dimensional object kind of sliced
through using this
this simplex implementation but this is
a very very common tool for introducing
movement into into generative art cool
so art wouldn't be generative art
without algorithms and so here I want to
talk a little bit about just a common
algorithm class and a couple of
different different algorithms in this
class of algorithms the this is a piece
that I did call acid city and the whole
thing revolves around like a Markov
chain based subdivision algorithm of
quadrilaterals and this is kind of a
simplified version of what I'm doing
there so imagine you have solved a
quadrilateral what's happening here is
at every I'm basically doing a recursive
algorithm where the quadrilateral splits
over and over and over again and the way
that it splits is it looks for either a
horizontal or a vertical slice to kind
of cut the thing in half and then it
uses a normally distributed variable to
kind of shift around that slice and if
you pay like really close attention
you'll see that on each successive
iteration of this it looks like it kind
of alternates between vertical and
horizontal slicing and that's just an
implementation detail where like I'm I'm
taking the the previous state and kind
of trying to do the opposite most of the
time but this is a really effective a
really effective algorithm it's kind of
visually appealing just in this basic
state and it's not very hard to do so it
makes it very it makes it a very like
attractive thing to start trying so this
is subdivision of quadrilaterals cool so
the next thing I want to talk about is
chikan curve subdivision this is a like
a modified subdivision algorithm and
what I mean by that is the idea is to
subdivide line segments like we talked
about earlier but the way that the the
line segments are subdivided is by
taking
a line segment and splitting it into
three parts the part between 0 and 25
percent apart between 75% and a hundred
percent and then the middle part the 25%
to 75% but the key here is that you drop
the endpoints and only keep the middle
segment and what this ends up doing is
approximating a curve for a bunch of
control points it's a super super simple
algorithm but it's extremely effective
and like it'll take you ten minutes to
write but this is kind of what it
produces so this is kind of the same
same generation algorithm as the as the
path that we saw earlier but I'm running
in iterative chikan curve subdivision on
it and so you can kind of see it just
approximates this over time super clever
that's one of my favorite algorithms I
love it okay so we haven't talked about
color at all and the the main thing that
I want to say about color is that it's
extremely difficult it's much much much
harder than you might expect the it you
can use completely random colors and
that's probably not going to turn out
super well you can also use color
palettes that are generated by other
people on the internet that can work
I've done that in the past and it's
worked ok but in general it it's one of
those things that's really difficult to
wrap your head around but I do have one
piece of advice that I like to give to
people and it's to avoid RGB because RGB
is really difficult for us to think
about like if if you wanted me to
generate like a pastel yellow and in RGB
coordinates I would have absolutely no
idea how to do that
so what I like to use is HSV HSV is a
color space that stands for hue
saturation and value and the idea is
that I mean you have three three
different components of this and you can
tweak them in in whatever way you want
but it's a lot easier to talk about hues
saturations and values so hue is some
number between 0 and 360 which
represents the degree value of your of
your hue
it starts at red and you know goes
through the rainbow and loops back
around to read the saturation is how how
like vibrant your color is like the
vibrancy of your color and a lot of in
in like the real world we don't have a
lot of super saturated colors so it's
nice to stick around kind of the middle
component of this and that's just some
floating-point value between zero and
one and then value is a number another
number between zero and one which
represents that lightness the the value
that we talked about when we were
talking about elements so it's nice to
have that kind of correspondence if you
ask me to generate like a pastel yellow
here and HSV I would say you know maybe
maybe like 40 degrees probably not very
saturated because it's a pastel color
and then the value of that will probably
be kind of high so a nice bright pastel
yellow it's much easier to talk about
HSV and I would recommend using it even
though a lot of times it's not the
default when you're working with
graphics libraries I will mention that
this piece right here uses a technique
that I called color bza too
it's beyond the scope of this talk but
I'd love to talk about it with anybody
afterwards if you're curious and I've
also done a couple of experiments with
like genetic algorithms trying to pit
color schemes against one another
and kind of evolved a good color scheme
that I like and that's kind of in early
stages I just I haven't gotten too far
with it yet but it's somewhat promising
so the next thing I want to talk about
here is texture this is another thing
that computers are good at but they
don't tell you they're good at it
so it's really compelling to draw a
square and just fill it because that's
really easy to do but we can introduce
texture into our generative art I was
inspired to do this experiment by this
guy Casimir Malevich came up with this
idea that he really wanted to paint a
black square back in 1915 and he just
became obsessed with the idea and ended
up you know doing this and now it's a
famous work of art but what I think is
kind of interesting about that is you
know he was probably thinking about
doing something so perfect and back in
1915 now that was really hard to do but
now we have computers and we can
basically replicate this process in two
seconds you know draw a square on a
screen and fill it with black so I
wanted to kind of flip that idea on its
head and in draw like a black square
that had texture involved like the
texture that he might have gotten from
the paint instead of just doing the easy
thing and filling it with black so this
is what I came up with it's pretty
simple so this is an animation of three
black squares each increasing in value
or decreasing in value I guess but the
idea if you look closely I'm just
generating a whole bunch of square
circles they have various radii and
positions within the circle but you
stack enough of them and you get this
kind of interesting texture I think that
as it gets darker it kind of reminds me
of if you were to take like a ballpoint
pen and just like scribble for a long
time but it's kind of this interesting
emergent property
that's super easy to do but you just
have to sort of think about texture a
little bit more when you're doing
generative art like I could have drawn
the black square with with a fill but
thinking about texture in this way kind
of tends to produce more interesting
things and it's not really that hard
given that computers are fast so it's
kind of fun and I used that technique in
this tile piece as well cool so now I
want to talk about the principle of
emergence this animation is paused for a
second because I want to explain what's
going to happen before it does so
imagine a square you can imagine a
square you guys can handle that now take
the midpoints of each edge of that
Square and connect them like you get a
little diamond shape and if you keep
doing that then you twist back into a
square and you twist into a diamond and
each respect and everything gets smaller
and you kind of converge on this cool
thing that's what this piece does but
what I'm doing is instead of using
squares I'm generating shapes from
randomly generated points at the top and
bottom of the image so there are a whole
bunch of points that are invisibly
generated at the top on the bottom
they're connected randomly and I run
this algorithm on the bunch of times to
and and then draw each successive
iteration and then they're clipped
inside these to offset rectangles so but
you'll see that the result is sort of
surprising it surprised me at least
yeah I think that's like a pretty neat
texture was something that I was
definitely not expecting but I was just
kind of messing around with the the
chikan curve algorithm actually and came
upon this because if you shrink the line
segment down to one point in the center
that's exactly what you get what I just
described instead of using the
traditional chikan curve algorithm to
shrink the the line segment a little you
shrink it all the way down to the center
of the of the point and yeah this was
one of the first pieces that I ever
printed and sold so I have a soft spot
for it but I just really like the
animation I think it's kind of fun but
on the idea of the principle of
emergence this I didn't expect to happen
and it did happen and you can kind of
see that there's just there's this
structure here that you might not be
able to figure out if you were to look
at it without my explanation and that's
kind of what the principle of emergence
is all about cool so that's pretty much
all I've got it I I want to encourage
people to go try this stuff out on their
own so there are a bunch of different
libraries that will do this some of them
that are very commonly used are like
processing and it's JavaScript
counterpart p5.js I personally is the
Cairo graphics toolkit I use bindings
from Haskell to talk to the C library
pyro
open frameworks is kind of this
collection of things a lot of
audio-visual designers will use it and
do generative work with that so find the
library start messing with it and find a
community the community around
generative art is often just called
generative we are in a lot of places we
were on Twitter Instagram there's a
really great subreddit if you're into
that but you know the hashtag generative
will get you a community of people we're
friendly and we like to help so if
you're at all interested in this kind of
thing I encourage you to give it a shot
and yeah make art
[Applause]
I do have a couple of questions if you
all are interested the first question
here is how do you pick the best
iteration of the art when you're
generating it that is really hard I the
the piece of this that I didn't talk
about is that half of generative art I
think is curation a whole lot of
figuring out which things to publish and
show it's just a giant component of it
and for me it's a lot of times it's just
hard like I've gotten better at it over
time and I don't really know how to
answer the question but eventually I
just kind of will come upon something
that I like I'll generate you know
hundreds of images and choose my
favorites it's kind of this arbitrary
game of like I don't know which one I
like better but I'll I just you
eventually have to pick something so I
try not to block myself with that
process because it's very easy to but
I'll say that I've become a better
curator just by doing this like just
constantly critiquing what pops out of
the computer the next question here have
you seen quill enclosure what's your
opinion so quill is our bindings to
processing in closure I actually used
that to start out with and I ended up
switching because there were just a
click I've been writing Haskell code for
seven years and I'm much more
comfortable with it so switching to
closure was fun for a little while I did
it for about a month every day and
ultimately I ended up having like a
couple of issues that I just kind of got
frustrated with but I mean your mileage
may vary like a great deal if you're
already a closure developer then it's a
great Avenue to explore the next thing
here
can you speak a little more on the sweet
spot regarding control yeah so if you've
noticed like a lot of my a lot of my
artwork has some static components to it
like these last two on the last slide
here like the one on the left is there's
a circle and there's a triangle and
those are explicitly placed there I
those aren't there's very little
randomness involved in choosing those
things and it's the same thing on the
right there's three squares those three
squares exist in every iteration of this
art but on the other hand like the the
textures on the on the piece on the left
are going to be completely different
iteration to iteration and on the right
like those squares get filled up in
different ways and so that's kind of
what I mean like you have to be you have
to I onder's Hoff talks about this he's
another generative artist he goes by in
convergent but he calls himself a
shepherd of random numbers and that's
kind of what I that's kind of what I
mean like you you sort of have to
finagle the randomness into something
that actually looks good without being
too chaotic another good example is if
you recall the slide where I had the the
squares and I just was dotting them and
then you look at where did I put this
randomness where is it here these pieces
the the dotson in in the rectangles here
are not uniformly distributed although
you might think that they were but using
a different random generation scheme
this is actually called poisson
distribution gives you kind of a nicer
distribution of the dots it's that sort
of thing like you don't want things to
be too random because they don't look
good and they're also kind of static
components of the pieces I hope that
answers the question and then the last
thing here is why experimenting in a
strongly typed language
that is personal preference I've found
it a lot easier to kind of catch my
errors upfront and and I found it a lot
easier to make changes that I kind of
can control yeah I mean it's kind of
just a it's also a matter of familiarity
like I said I've been writing high
school for seven years and so it's a
it's a familiarity thing for me for sure
that's all I've got on here anybody have
any other questions that's a really good
question so the question was do you ever
use real-world data to generate
randomness I haven't I have used like
MIDI files and done like data
visualizations and interesting ways and
that kind of thing but in terms of using
it as a source of random data I haven't
done that mm-hmm yep
so can you repeat the question yeah okay
so the question I think is do you see
this the computational part of this as
just a method of creation versus like is
it interesting in its own right okay
yeah I mean I think it's both I think
it's kind of interesting in its own
right
because it it kind of forces us to think
about art in a kind of meta way like I
have to so a lot of times I'll try to
mimic things that I'm that I would do
with drawing you know like or I'll see
other traditional artists kind of doing
something in some style and trying to
mimic that is in itself kind of an
interesting thing like trying to codify
what actual artists are doing but I mean
it's also the other way it's also a
means to an end like it's also a way for
for me to kind of for me to create so
yeah I hope that answers your question
anything else we got two minutes yes
I do not but I know a lot of other
people do do that for me so the random
generation part I've I've done something
kind of similar to that which I'll
describe so all of my images are seated
and if I run the program again with the
same seed it'll generate the same art
what's interesting though is if you find
a seed that you kind of like the way
that the random generation happened so
for example if I'm generating a bunch of
lines and I like the way that they
showed up on the screen I can tweak
things that are not random in that
program run it with the same seed and
get something slightly different so like
if I if I find an image that I like but
I don't like the color scheme I can run
it with the same seed switch up the
color scheme and kind of see how how
that looks instead but in terms of like
loading it into Photoshop or something
and tweaking it manually I have not done
any of that yes
so the question was do I know of any
artists who are using interactive work
as a source for four random generation
yeah I don't actually that that sounds
super interesting there might be people
out there I don't know of everybody but
I've never heard of that we are about at
time so if you have any other questions
feel free to come up and talk to me
after the talk
[Applause]